to me hi hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to
subnautica now I know I said that I
wasn't going to be back into the game
until there was a major update or the
full release of the game and thankfully
that wait is over they just released the
voice of the deep update and this is why
I waited to go in there I waited to see
what was going to happen if we were
gonna use the hatching enzymes on those
egg oh all right then
sorry oh hi okay I'm getting it now okay
anyway the reason I waited is because
this update is major this entire
research facility is now fully
operational and we have everything that
we need to be able to get what we need
to get my god
okay alrighty then
if that's what you say okay so oh hi
hello ah god damn it get off my boat you
frickin Fricks
but either way the update is here and
this precursor base is fully operational
alongside every single one of those
ding-dang portals at least me thinks so
me not sure so but me go look at it so I
just came in here to get some more food
so that I can make it through all the
research that I'm gonna need to do to be
able to get through all of this and once
I get a marbled melon
I guess that's enough for me I hope I
don't puke okay there we go
one more okay we're good to go so if we
go down in here we're gonna see
everything that is available to us why
is this a low oh why are you so creepy
why are you so roar why don't you go
[ __ ] her oh I gotta get those guys off
there but I gotta get in here before the
lag takes Pete hi okay we're in and so
right now you guys will see there's an
actual honest-to-goodness terminal here
I don't have to hack my way in anymore
open it goodbye blue key barely I'm
gonna take mr. Pfister in here and we're
gonna see our own wager oh we're gonna
see everything that we need to see how
you skittering bastards boingy now it
should look much the same as it did
before there shouldn't be a whole lot
new here so I'm only gonna go over the
things that are definitely new like this
research terminal right here so I think
I've read that before that's talking
about the Emperor and them containing it
here so so that means this is the
complete egg research area all of the
Emperor's
[Music]
why would the killer baby I mean to
research the disease and try to save
lives I guess Oh superficial damage to
the specimen indicates who was forcibly
removed from its egg casing terminated
for dissection digestive system enzyme
production indicates potential for full
vaccination against effects Balian
bacterium how our fetus had not fully
completed gestation internal organ
development is insufficient for enzyme
production ah okay so they needed a
healthy baby but they decided to cut one
out of an egg for no goddamn reason I
may have read that before but I am
equally outraged now the update
mentioned something about the piping
project now I glanced over this in this
unfinished area over here Oh over here
and I mentioned that there was these
pipes here these fascinating
otherworldly pipes pumping water to and
from the attached pipe network analysis
the water composition flowing in it
indicates it is being drawn from the
different biomes now we read that before
but the revelation that I didn't realize
before is that the reason this all
exists is number one to be able to
contain the biomes with which to
research the specimens that they contain
here in this facility but also as an
added ancillary benefit the peepers that
live in the tank with the Emperor
Leviathan Traverse to and from this area
and back to the surface there goes one
and with it contained some of enzyme 42
and enzyme 42 is the thing that makes
sure that the life on this planet is
still alive
there's a reason while life is still
here while the core our bacterium was
still raging everywhere and why it still
infected me and yet everything else is
still alive
and maybe even why the people of this
place like the humans that landed here
before why they were able to survive so
long if they were eating if they were
eating the creatures here then that
would explain why they were able to
survive for so long I don't have another
blue one there another blue one in here
you guys seen a blue or and I'll be back
with you I hope I don't have to make one
because I did not come up with the I
didn't come up with the plans for the
correct one so I've discovered the
location of the blue artifact it is
obviously still in the primary power
plant
which is above us in the lava castle as
its colloquially known but I was
supposed to be able to get a crafting
recipe once I pick that up right I have
to go get it because I believe all of
the spawns should have reset so that
means there should be another one up
there and I ain't gonna cheat and get
one I'm gonna do that so I'll be right
back in a minor adventure to be able to
get that before I have to go on go
forward so I'll see you soon
Oh also I should mention that there have
been updates to this now the engine is
offline and you have to turn it back on
are you just gonna join us for the ride
fine that seems unnecessary that's right
you can rig for silent running now so
you can be silent at any speed
that is the opposite of silent oh god
I'll be okay are we okay we're not okay
are we
oh that seems the opposite okay okay ah
[ __ ] oh god the dubsteps gonna start
pounding oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh they're all mad at me launch decoy
guru ski didn't help literally and oh
they're going for it oh my god they're
going for oh this is an adventure that I
didn't want to undertake oh there's
gonna be a tight squeeze
oh that's whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo why didn't I
take Mike why didn't I take mr. Pfister
oh my god paper in my face go down my
bare skin v's and with that comes the
cup of how give give give give give to
me thank you
I got a blueprint with that which I
should have gotten a long time ago but
he didn't so if I go then back into the
depths of hell there's a bit of
destruction just world
that seems a bit extreme I got a good to
hear that before it burns my ass to
Smith
like the big momma dump don't wanna be
Girls Island hey you can't hear me I
don't know what you're talking about
we got an emergency speed we're gunning
it out my ass I am NOT going to bother
you until I punch you in your dick and
when I do that you'll be like oh thank
you markiplier they're so nice
okay that was a goddamn nightmare that
was a nightmare unlike any I've seen
before but we're back so we have the
blue artifact so there is no more
waiting here there is no more skedaddle
skadoodle I meant to just go straight
through this but it's decided to be a
little bit of a douche so oh yeah there
you go
it's weird and as simple as that this
supposed power supply is just meant to
take down the power of a shield okay by
the way this is ooh translating local
alien broadcast warning vaccine
development program terminated emperor
egg hatching project terminated live
specimen terminate evacuate immediately
well I think you're wrong about one
thing here there's a Gersh Dern live
specimen alive right in here
Hey hi mama the others came along now
they're gone and it says I
yeah you do hey my name is markiplier
how you doing how long you been down
here I'm uh here to play hey wait no
come on I said my name is markiplier
that usually gets um
Oh Big Momma I've been waiting for this
day oh don't worry
I'm here to play would you like to play
a game hello can I help you excuse me oh
my what big legs you have Oh passive
barbara's oh all right all right no way
Genki a little bit but alright okay let
me step out for a little bit
mmm rare plankton like life-form oh wait
I can breathe down here wait no I can't
that was a lie just suffer hi hi mama
how are you doing oh these your kids
oh they're lovely they take after their
mother if you know what I mean ha ha ha
yeah oh I need to I need to fuel it ah
that'd be smart oh yeah take my fuel oh
that one worked
outside this place we have been here so
long the others have ways of giving
passage to the outside I asked them for
this that they could not hear
thank you thank you thank you what did
they want to know was it how do cure was
it how to cure tell me it was how to
cure I'm tingling all right so now if I
get hatching enzymes I'll be able to
yeah what I need to get and hatch these
eggs but how do I get hatching enzymes
you might ask well I think the answer
might lie in waiting right over you
excuse me sir I've got destiny calling
okay all right well
be forced from their shelves they must
be coaxed this is what the others cannot
see I
the secret willingly I hope I will not
be disappointed again oh you shouldn't
have trusted me I'm gonna milk make
millions off of these hahahaha okay how
do I make this uh hatching enzymes here
all right Gabe's feather seed sea crown
seed membrane tootsie aye
what are those what are those I don't
even know what those are
what are those are you bowing that's so
sweet
and misguided I don't deserve that I'm
an [ __ ] all right I don't know where
we're going now
I hope it's somewhere clean I pissed
myself
all right fine you won't play that game
huh okay well I guess that gets me to
the surface quick but this is it this is
what I've been waiting for where'd you
go Oh who's there it's just dark in here
now oh there you are okay the lights
decided to come in here but that's what
I've been waiting for that's what I've
been waiting for oh I want to work for
it I don't even know what these are
what are those what's Gabe's feather
what's the C ground what's the membrane
tree I think I know what the membrane
trees that the big thing with the thing
I don't know what's a Rouge cradle I've
got a whole new adventure ahead of me
and many more episodes of subnautica
waiting so that I can hatch these damn
eggs and see if I can cure myself so Big
Momma don't wait too long you ain't
gonna be disappointed about nothing oh
you winked at me I saw that so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for being patient for the return of
subnautica
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]